introducing iphone 12. okay
one iphone this is iphone 12 mini
uh two this is iphone 12 pro
three and iphone 12 pro max increases
from today's 6.5 inch
to a more expansive 6.7 inch display
really four four iphone 12s yes at a
virtual event on tuesday apple released
four iphone 12s each with 5g
a new design oled screens and new camera
tricks
now typically i'd be on the ground in
cupertino
ruthlessly fighting other tech
journalists to get my hands on the
newest phones
and tell you my first thoughts damn look
how close we used to get to people
but this year nope there's still a lot
to explain because again
four phones but before we get into each
model let's talk about what's the same
across the entire lineup
whether you pay 699 or 1100
the most obvious new thing a new
squarish design with colored glass backs
here it is a first look at the iphone 12
just joking it's an iphone 4.
it really was a beautiful beautiful
phone next they each have
5g connectivity which apple made a big
deal about
this is a huge moment for all of us and
we're really excited
the issue for me is that very high speed
5g is very limited in the us right now
so even if it is that fast not everyone
is going to get those speeds
or even see a 5g indicator 5g
simply isn't a reason to upgrade on its
own
then they all have new a14 bionic
processors
which are of course faster than last
year's processors
and you know they're good for things
like gaming and augmented reality
one big difference this year all the
phones have super retina xdr displays
or oled screens the phone screens also
have what apple calls a ceramic shield
which is said to provide four times
better drop performance
of course i'll have to test that for
myself inside there's a big change too
there's a magnetic disc in the back of
the phones called magsafe
yep like those old macbook chargers this
enables accessories to snap to the back
of the phone
i'm most excited about the new apple
wireless charger that's capable of up to
15 watt charging speeds
speaking of charging there are no
charging adapters in the box
just usbc to lightning cords apple says
it's better for the earth which reduces
carbon emissions and avoids the mining
and use of precious materials okay those
are all the things that are the same but
what's actually different about each of
them
mostly price screen size and camera
features
let's run down the models from lowest
cost to highest
number one iphone 12 mini starting at
6.99
the mini has a 5.4 inch screen which
means
it's mini but only in comparison to the
other 6.1 and 6.7 inch models
just a little reminder the original
iphone was actually mini it had a 3.5
inch screen
but for real this new mini looks
adorable and great for those of us who
don't love giant screens
it also has an aluminum design and comes
in five colors
it has two 12 megapixel cameras on the
back a wide angle and an ultra wide
angle camera
all the cameras are now capable of night
mode and have hdr3
aka crisper more detailed shots they
also have improved video capture
number two the iphone 12 starting at 799
dollars
this is easy the iphone 12 is the exact
same as the mini
except it has a 6.1 inch screen that's
it a hundred dollars more for just a
bigger screen
number three the iphone 12 pro starting
at 999
the iphone pro has a 6.1 inch screen and
unlike those other iphone 12 models
aluminum designs
it has a more premium stainless steel
design in four new colors
the big difference comes in the cameras
it has a triple camera system
a telephoto a wide and an ultra white
the ultra wide camera now has a wider
aperture which apple says offers 27
percent
better low light performance the new pro
models also have
lidar a depth sensor that helps with
augmented reality apps
but also should help with auto focus and
low light photo improvements
number four the iphone 12 pro max
starting at 1 099
the promax has the same design as the
pro but steps it up with a 6.7 inch
screen
it also has an improved telephoto camera
capable of up to 2.5
optical zoom the two pro models will
also be able to shoot better hdr video
all in all it's one of the biggest
iphone leaps in years
but which of the four do you get stay
tuned for when i actually get my hands
on these phones
i'll have reviews in the coming weeks
i'm not really sure it's
minnie